Let's look at the solution to our BTB and BHT quiz. The question this time is,
which BHT entry do we access for each
instruction? There are 16 entries in the BHT,
and we said that we access the BHT
using the lowermost bits of the instruction address.
That they are not the same for all
instructions. In this case, our instruction address has
the following bits. For the move instruction here we have C000, because every
instruction is 4 bytes in size, the
lower most 2-bits are never changing; they're
always going to be 0 for our instructions. And now because
we have 16 BHT entries, we take the next 4 bits and this is the number of
the BHT entry. In this case we're accessing the BHT entry number 0. Now
let's look at this other move instruction here whose address is C004. C00 are
not changing, what is changing is 4. Four in binary 0100. Again we discard
these bits because they're never changing among
instructions, and this is the number of the
BHT entry. So the entry that we access here is 1. Now you can tell that for
instruction 8 here, this is going to be 10, so we are going to access the
BHT entry number 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 and 7. If we reached 15 we
will then wrap around to 0, but we never reach it. So this is really what we get